The grammar is something that
we do care about, but it's not
something that should be upfront.
Hi, Steve Kaufmann here.
Today I want to talk about the
fifth of my, uh, hierarchy of
goals and, uh, and that's grammar.
Um, some people may think that, or
at least in traditional language
instruction, grammar was the first goal:
get it right.
Uh, But before I go any further
to remember if you enjoy these
videos, um, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
And um, if you follow me on a podcast
service, uh, please leave a comment.
We do appreciate it.
So, I mean, typically we're
used to the idea that language
instruction involves grammar.
It involves the teacher explaining grammar
rules, which are introduced one at a time,
according to, you know, order that someone
decided we begin with the present tense
and not the past tense, no real reason.
Uh, typically in Arabic, they
begin with the past tense and
then move to the present tense.
Um, so there seems to be this order in
which grammar concepts are introduced
and then we're tested on them, or
we do exercises on them and the
sort of the core element in language
instruction seems to be grammar.
Everything is built around grammar, uh,
typically in these textbooks that will
be, um, you know, content items, items of
content, uh, to introduce new vocabulary.
But together with that,
inevitably there is a concept
of grammar that is introduced.
To me, grammar or speaking
correctly, or correct usage as
a goal it's way down the list.
All right.
You, by now will know that I consider
acquiring words as the first goal,
getting a lot of words, uh, getting
to where I can start reading in
the language is the second goal.
The third goal is listening and of course
the reading helps you with listening.
Cause if I just hear it, I don't
necessarily know what I'm missing.
Uh, and then I get to speaking because
now I've been listening to so much
of the language that I have words,
I feel that I'm ready to speak.
And so it's only when I start speaking
that my inaccuracy in the language
becomes a problem because as long as I'm
input based, I'm listening and reading,
I'm requiring words, I can actually
understand fairly well what's happening.
I have some concepts of the grammar,
but because I'm not producing much of
the language, I'm not making mistakes.
So it's a happy situation.
I'm enjoying the language,
no pressure, no mistakes.
Now, once I start speaking, then
of course we all would like to
speak more correctly, more...
the usage patterns, we want to imitate
the usage patterns of the native speaker.
To some extent, if we put a lot of effort
into our listening and reading and we
have lots of words, we will have a...
begin to have a feel for how
the language works, but, and we
will notice certain patterns.
And we will notice that for example,
the verb comes at the end for example.
We don't have to be told that, that
becomes pretty obvious pretty quickly.
Although if we're told that upfront,
there's nothing wrong with that either.
But so much of what is in grammar, at
least in the initial stages in my approach
is just to be kind of vaguely aware that
these things exist in the language without
necessarily expecting to remember it.
But comes a point now where I'm
speaking and I always make...
struggle to get my thoughts out.
And I'm not quite sure how that
structure works, even though I've
seen it, I'm not able to produce it.
And so now we really have to focus in,
on, on producing the language correctly.
And so, but the advantage is if we
start focusing in on grammar after
having put enough effort into the
input we now have some idea of what the
grammar explanations refer to because
we've already experienced much of it.
And so we look at the grammar rule,
we still can't apply it, but I
think that studying grammar after a
significant exposure to the language
helps us grasp these grammar rules.
And even if we forget them and we look at
them again and we look at them again and
we look it up again, slowly, our ability
to use the grammar correctly improves.
And I don't think it's
necessary to be tested on them.
I think it's enough to review the
grammar rules, try to notice them
when we're listening and reading.
And I've always found that in
time if I have enough words,
I'll be able to start speaking.
So the grammar is something that
we do care about, but it's not
something that should be upfront.
And because I'm very much focused on
input based learning, I would like to
see more grammar books where concepts
of grammar are introduced in the target
language in Spanish and Japanese.
And that there is a company audio for that
lesson so that I can go away and I can
listen to a discussion of the subjunctive
in Spanish with a lot of examples and
I can listen to it and I can read it so
that it becomes a lesson like any other
lesson and I'm learning the grammar
rules, but in the target language, I'm
not sure if resources like that exist.
Um, I've often...
I haven't had that so what I've
relied upon is grammar resources
that I can find on the internet.
I can download a PDF of Romanian grammar.
I can look up specifics of, you know,
Ukrainian noun declensions, or anything
really that you need to look up.
Uh, you can look it up.
And, uh, certainly with verbs,
uh, at LingQ, we have conjugating
dictionaries in many cases.
So as you look up a form of the verb,
it'll tell you which form it is and
it'll show you the other, uh, you
know, conjugations of that verb.
So there's so many resources around that
help us treat grammar as something that
we refer to rather than something that has
to be deliberately learned and certainly
not deliberately learned upfront.
So, and with that, I find over time,
my accuracy, it gets better and,
but there will always be mistakes.
And in many cases, I'll make
the same mistake week after
week, month after month.
And eventually these mistakes
do correct themselves.
So grammar therefore or correct
usage is for me, uh, in my hierarchy
of goals number five, not one, not
two, not three, not four but five.
Okay.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.